my name is Betances shook I'm originally
from central part of Ukraine I used to
be a journalist and also an activist now
I'm in the parliament and I'm member of
the committee for foreign affairs it was
a sad day actually when we found out
that cabinet of ministers refused to
continue with association agreement with
European Union my friend mother fan i am
called me and said we have to go into
the street and we have to show up to our
power that we do not agree with what
they've done it was not revolution of
elite or opposition in the country it
was revolution of really civil society
that decided that we have to leave a
different way and what we said this time
to our leaders of a position that you
have to deliver and we're going to be
critical we're going to monitor but the
main thing is that the DNA of this
society has changed dramatically it is
irreversible and sooner or later we'll
come to the point when will see that we
leave already in a different country
you